thousands of British ambulance drivers
were expected to walk off the job
Wednesday joining an estimated 10 000
nurses who began striking the day before
and adding to the unprecedented pressure
on the British Health Care System unions
point out that record inflation has
eaten into employee wages for nurses
that's made an already difficult job
even harder
Emily laches one of thousands of nurses
in London who was going on strike for
the first time in her life her demands
go away Beyond higher wages I'm tired of
coming into work and it being
understaffed you know I've got many
colleagues that mental health is
suffering patients are suffering and I
want to see A Change Is sentiment shared
by her colleagues who've walked out of
Saint Thomas Hospital their Union the
Royal College of Nursing is calling for
better pay it wants wages to be raised
five percent above retail inflation that
would amount to a 19 hike the nurses
Union also want the government to fill a
record number of Staff vacancies 50 000
in total it says
you don't go into nursing for the money
you go into care for your patients but I
feel like we're all at breaking point
it's a similar situation across Britain
here in Liverpool nurses say they are
overworked and underpaid but recession
hit Britain cannot afford to match the
nurses Union's demands the government
says
if you wanted to treat yourself for
luxuries you would work a bank shift or
overtime I find now that I'm having to
work Bank shifts and overtime just to
make ends meet and it's really difficult
people are not managing we've got a food
bank set up in our trust that nurses and
other staff members are having to access
to feed the families no it's not enough
it's not enough
back in London ordinary car drivers are
honking to show support for the nurses
demands for better pay
when inflation is factored in real wages
for nurses dropped 1.2 percent annually
between 2010 and 2017 according to the
uk-based charity Health Foundation
nurses are unlikely to drop their
demands amid the ongoing cost of living
crisis
[Applause]
figgy price is chief economic advisor
for the center for economics and
business research in London Vicki thanks
for joining the show I'm struck by the
nurse we just heard who's heard who said
that the shifts she once worked to have
more pocket cash for luxury items or
whatever she wanted to buy she now needs
to work them just to get by is this
becoming a more typical story across the
UK
well it is and what we're seeing of
course is that inflation like in other
countries uh has increased out of sort
of anyone's expectations partly because
of course the war in Ukraine and wages
have not kept up uh with that and what's
going on of course across the economy is
that a real household disposable incomes
are declining and then declining by
something like 2.7 if you look at wages
um themselves so this on the one hand
you've got these are the costs and tax
increases that everyone is suffering
from at present but you've also got of
course wages not keeping up uh with
inflation if you look particularly in
the public sector which is uh you know
where of course the nurses that we just
heard work for and what you've seen is
that they have lagged behind the private
sector itself so they've been rising for
something like 2.7 2.9 over the last uh
year uh when inflation of course is over
10 the private sector has done slightly
better what we've seen there is that
they're getting increases of over six
percent it's still not not enough of
course to make up for that Gap in in
real learnings but nevertheless there is
a gap between private and public sector
which has been increasing recently and
it's one of the largest that we have
seen in ages
I think you've also read somewhere that
the UK is still suffering from the Great
Recession that occurred more than a
decade ago would you say that's true
especially when you look at these public
sector wages
well yes I mean we had the uh the
financial crisis and of course the UK
was affected by that quite significantly
by comparison to other countries given
very strong financial sector that we had
and still have actually
um what it had meant of course in terms
of what the government did
um to rectify if you like the situation
uh was enter into big austerity program
that was territory program through uh
the decade that followed meant that a
lot of spending on public services was
cut in real terms and we are suffering
in the National Health Service right now
from those cuts so it is an issue and of
course the pay has not kept up with
inflation anyway during that period when
those cuts were taking place and that's
one of the Grievances if you like that
public sector workers now have that they
have fallen so behind that the increases
they're asking for now which look
unmanageable by the government
um are to make up for all those losses
they've had all these years
to what extent if any is brexit also
playing a role in these crises that
we're seeing when it comes to wages when
it comes to a rising prices
well that's interesting because of
course it has a different sectors in
different ways so if you look at the
economy across uh you know the the whole
sort of area where particularly EU
workers were very important what you
find is that there are sectors which
have suffered quite significantly
because of the exit if you like of uh
people who were part of the labor force
but decided partly after covert but also
because of brexit not to come back or
Now find it difficult to get back and
work in the UK so the hospitality sector
retail wholesale quite a large part of
construction in London in particular was
banned by EU workers so that has been a
source of
um shortages if you like which have been
seen both in the private sector the
areas that I mentioned but also in the
public sector nurses for example so we
have had conditions get worse for the
NHS because not only do you have an
increased demand because of covid flu
and everything else we've seen in the
last few months and last couple of years
but also you have a shortage of people
which means that working conditions for
the nurses and everyone who works in the
National Health Service have worsened
also they claim and is part of what
they're asking for they want a change in
the way in which you know everything is
organized if you want to ask prime
minister Rishi sunak saying that the
best way to help nurses and everyone
else is to reduce inflation as quickly
as possible he also said that inflation
will make people poor in the long run
that's not untrue but what policy
options does Downing Street really have
to address this briefly if you can
yes well they they could uh raise taxes
in various ways and and pay for more of
those increases but it's absolutely true
that inflation is an issue and needs to
be dealt with and and people are feeling
quite uh you know much poorer because of
what's going on and we've seen that they
have been keeping up spending or just
deeping into their savings so that's a
problem there's no doubt that inflation
is is bad news but in terms of nurses
and the public sector in particular
um you could raise their their um
salaries without having a direct impact
on inflation because you're not going to
increase the cost of the NHS to
individuals so you can't raise your
prices it's not as if you're talking
about other parts of the economy where
perhaps you know the producers could
pass it all on to the consumers you
can't do that very easily in the public
sector yes so the wage spiral coming
from the the uh Public Service increases
in in their pay is likely to be a lot
more less than in the private sector
except in areas like rail strikes for
example the railway workers where you
could in fact see transport fares go up
but overall they're much less
inflationary than would otherwise be the
case we'll have to leave it there for
now Vicky price the center for economics
and business research in London thank
you very much
thank you